how are you pretty how are you look at
this giving me some hollywood glams
oh my gosh you look the part are you
having fun already you're no stranger to
this event i'm having a great time
friends are here i'm excited yay
is the family here is it no it's just me
good girl's gotta have her moment out
and about on the town too i miss them i
hate not having them here good dixie
come on now girl i saw the trailer for
the upcoming season is there a little
sibling rivalry there when it comes to
like you guys wanting to be your own
people you know step out from the gram
and social media platforms no we're best
friends
yeah so that was just a suspense that
was to stir up drama
like you'll see it in the show what
we're talking about specifically but
we're best friends okay and mermaids
fair enough now
tell me this are we going to see the
show your sister and your mama out there
competing on dancing with the stars i
don't know you know that's what the
rumor mills saying is the rumor mill
right dixie
i cannot confirm or deny this
information
mostly because i just don't know i'm
actually
you know everything missy you know
everything well
it'll be interesting to see those two
battle it out on the ballroom floor for
sure and of course the new season of
y'all show uh happy belated birthday oh
my gosh thank you
how much time did you have celebrating
in vegas if you recovered yes it was a
great time
it was fun nice time yeah
is it true that you helped your set your
sister up with her latest spo is that
correct
were you playing a little matchmaker i
mean i
might have put the idea out there yeah i
don't know yeah you were totally
shipping that idea what do you think
what do you make of your sis and landed
together i just love that she's happy
and i just want her to be happy whatever
she does
[Music]